PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome back.
I hope you had a nice break.
The midterms will be handed out
at the end of the class.
Ashish has just gone to
get them in my office.
With solutions.
I hope you look at
the solutions.
There's more in the solutions
than is strictly necessary.
The midterm is partly intended
as a learning exercise, and I
hope you learned something
from it.
I didn't learn too much from
it about the performance of
the class, because some of the
questions were easy enough
that practically everybody
got them, and some of the
questions were too hard
for anybody to get.
And so the distribution --
you know, what I would really
like to get is a nice
bell-shaped curve going from 0
to 100 with a median at 50 and
the standard deviation
about 25.
And I got a much more compressed
curve than that.
So frankly, I didn't learn
that much about relative
performance.
And I gather from Ashish that
you've all been doing the
homeworks, and have been doing
a fairly steady job on that.
So I think everybody is
close to being in
the same boat here.
If anybody has concerns about
their performance, of course
they're welcome to talk to me.
Drop date is a little
while off.
If you're concerned about what
your grade might be, I'll give
you the best idea I can.
But really, it's going
to come down to the
final for most of you.
So it's not too much
to say here.
I give the grade distribution
and the midterm solutions, and
from that, you could figure out
where you are relatively.
And my grading philosophy is at
MIT, in graduate classes,
roughly they're half
As and half Bs.
I have that as a guideline
in mind.
I try to look for where the
natural breaks are.
I decorate the As and Bs with
pluses and minuses, but I
don't think anybody pays
attention to those.
And in other words, I generally
try to follow the
MIT grading philosophy
as I understand it.
So are there any questions about
the midterm or anything
about the class as we go
into the second half?
No?
I see some people
aren't back yet.
It's a somewhat reduced group.
Maybe a couple people decided
to drop on the
basis of the midterm.
That sometimes happens.
I don't think it necessarily
had to happen this year.
Or maybe people are just having
an extended break.
OK.
We're now going into
conceptually a break, the
second half of the course.
The first half of the course we
were talking about trying
to get to capacity, specifically
on the additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
So far all the schemes that
we've talked about have been
block coding schemes, which
their Euclidean images wind up
to be constellations in a finite
dimensional space.
This is the kind of picture that
Shannon had when he wrote
his original paper on capacity
and information, to start off
information theory.
Basically he proved that you
could get to capacity on any
channel with a randomly
chosen code.
In the setting where we are,
that would be a randomly
chosen binary code where you
just pick all the bits of all
the code words at random
by flipping a coin.
OK?
Just construct a code book at
random, and as the code gets
long enough, that's
going to be good
enough to get to capacity.
It's a block code.
2 to the nr bits, and length
n code words where r is the
regular code.
Well, that was a brilliant
achievement, to show that you
could get to capacity
by doing that.
If you can do it by choosing
codes at random, then there
must be some particular
codes that are good.
Otherwise the average overall
codes wouldn't be good.
So people started to go out
to find good codes.
And there was a fairly quick
realization that Shannon
hadn't addressed some key
parts of the problem.
Particularly the complexity
of encoding and decoding.
The complexity of encoding was
pretty quickly recognized to
be not much of an issue, because
Peter Elias and others
proved that, at least for the
kinds of channels we're
talking about, which are
symmetric, linear codes are
just as good.
A random linear code will
get to capacity.
In other words, say, a block
code with a randomly chosen
generator matrix.
You pick k generators of length
n, again by flipping a
coin, that's good enough
to get to capacity.
So we know we can encode linear
codes with polynomial
complexity.
It's just the matrix
multiplication to encode a
linear block code.
All right?
So encoding isn't the problem.
But decoding.
What kind of decoding have
we talked about so far?
I guess particularly with Reed
Solomon codes, we've talked
about algebraic methods.
But our generic method is
to do maximum likelihood
decoding, which basically
involves computing a distance
or a metric to each
of the code words.
Exponential number
of code words.
2 to the nr code words.
So we have exponential
complexity if we do maximum
likelihood or minimum
distance decoding.
And that, of course, was the
motivation for doing some of
these algebraic decoding
methods, which were the
primary focus coding theory
for several decades.
A great deal of very good effort
went into finding good
classes of codes that were
algebraically decodable, like
Reed-Solomon codes, BCH codes,
Reed-Muller codes.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
don't have such --
well, they do, we now realize.
But that was the focus.
And with the algebraic coding
methods, there was polynomial
complexity.
But it began to be realized that
these were never going to
get you to capacity.
Because of their difficulty in
using reliability information,
because most of them are bounded
distance character,
and in fact, that's
still true.
You can't get to capacity with
algebraic decoding methods.
So in parallel with this work
on block codes, there was a
smaller stream of work that has
broadened, I would say, as
the ancestor of the
capacity-approaching codes of
today, on codes with other
kinds of structure.
And specifically dynamical
structure, which is what we're
going to talk about
when we talk about
convolutional codes.
And this was broadened into the
field of codes on graphs.
And codes on graphs are nowadays
the way we get to
channel capacity.
All right?
So that's really where we're
going in the second half of
the course.
We're going to preserve
linear structure.
Linear is always good for the
symmetric channels we're
talking about.
But in addition, we're going
to look for other kinds of
structure which are, in
particular, suitable for
lower-complexity decoding
methods, are suitable for
maximum likelihood or
quasi-maximum likelihood
decoding methods.
All right?
So that's our motivation.
OK.
Convolutional codes.
Convolutional codes were
actually invented by Peter
Elias in an effort to find --
just as you can put a linear
structure on codes without
harming their performance, he
was trying to find more and
more structure but you could put
on codes while still being
able to achieve capacity
with a random ensemble.
And he invented something called
sliding parity-check
codes, which, if you let the
block link go to infinity,
become convolutional codes.
And they say there was a trickle
of effort basically
motivated by the fact that
a number of people did a
practical comparison of
performance versus complexity.
Convolutional codes always
beat block codes.
And so, for instance, I was at
a small company was trying to
apply coding theory.
We quickly gravitated to
convolutional codes, because
they always gave us a better
performance complexity
straight off than block codes.
And I'm going to try to indicate
why that's so.
All right.
So I think the easiest way to
understand convolutional codes
is by example, by putting
down an encoder.
And the canonical example
everybody always uses is this
one, so why should I
be any different?
Here is a rate 1/2 constraint
length 2
convolutional encoder.
And it operates on a stream
of bits coming in.
So what we have here is a time
index stream of bits, uk.
And you can think of
this stream as
being infinite in length.
We'll talk about how to make
this a little bit more precise
as we go along.
And we have a shift register
structure here.
The incoming bit uk is
D means a memory
element or a delay element.
It goes into a flip-flop.
It's delayed for 1 time unit.
There's some discrete time base
going on here, which is
indexed by k.
So k is simply the set
of all integers.
Comes from the index set.
Here is u k.
Here's u k minus 1.
Here is u k minus 2.
All right?
And constraint length 2
means that we save --
we have the present
information bit.
This is called the input
or the information bit.
And the two past information
bits are saved.
And from that, we generate
two output bits.
y1 at time k is given by u k
plus u k minus 2, where this
is a mod 2 sum.
Everything is in f2.
y2k is the sum of u k plus u
k minus 1 plus u k minus 2.
All right?
So this is where we get
the redundancy.
What are we generally
doing with coding?
We're adding redundant bits in
order to get more distance
between the sequences that we
might send, and thereby
hopefully to get a coding gain
on the additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
Here the redundancy comes from
the fact that you get 2 bits
out for every bit
that you put in.
So there ought to be the
possibility of getting some
distance between possible
code sequences.
The code sequences here are
infinite or semi-infinite, but
nonetheless, we can establish
some minimum distance, or as
it's called in this field,
the free distance.
OK.
There are two kinds
of structure here.
First of all, this is a linear
time invariant system.
If we were talking about the
real or complex field, we
might call this a filter.
Or it's actually a single input,
two output filter.
So each of the y sequence
is a filtered
version of the u sequence.
y2 is a filtered version
of the u sequence.
And it's linear basically
because it's made up of linear
elements, lay elements,
and mod 2 adders.
Over the binary field, it's
time-invariant, because if I
change the time index,
it doesn't
really change the equation.
It's very hand-waving
rough here.
But so it's a linear
time-invariant system, and we
can analyze it the way
we analyze a filter.
It's redundant, so it has more
outputs than inputs, which we
want in a coding system.
But other than that, we're going
to find that the same
kind of techniques that we use
for analyzing discrete time
linear filters can be used
to analyze the system.
It's just over a different
field, F2, rather
than R or C. All right?
So that's one kind
of structure.
And secondly, it's a finite
state system.
Let's forget about
all the algebra.
There's a discrete time system
which has two memory elements
in it, each capable
of storing 1 bit.
So how many states are
there in the system?
Four.
There are four possible states
that reflect everything that
went on in the past.
That's all you need to know
about the future, is what the
state is at time k, to see
what's going to happen from
time k onwards.
All right?
So this is a simple four-state
system, in this case.
In general, if we build similar
encoders out of shift
registers, even if we put
feedback in them, it's going
to be a finite state system.
So we're going to restrict
ourselves to finite state
realizations, finite
state encoders.
And that's going to ultimately
be the basis for the decoding
algorithm, which is going to be
Viterbi algorithm, which is
a very efficient decoder for
any finite state system
observed in memoryless noise,
which is what we have here.
Hidden Markov model, as
it's sometimes called.
All right.
So we're going to interplay
these two types of structure.
And I feel it's really the fact
that convolutional codes
have these two kinds of
structure that makes them
better than block codes.
They have just the amount of
algebraic structure that we
want, namely, the linear
structure.
They don't have too
much algebraic
structure beyond that.
We don't have elaborate roots
of polynomials and so forth,
as we do with Reed-Solomon
codes.
We have a pretty modest
algebraic structure here.
And it's sort of different in
character than the algebraic
structure Reed-Solomon codes.
And it's married to this
finite state dynamical
structure, which is what
allows us to have
low-complexity decoding.
So that's kind of the magic
of convolutional codes.
Not that they're very magic.
All right.
This is a convolutional
encoder.
What is a convolutional code?
The convolutional code is
roughly the set of all
possible output sequences.
And this is where we're going
to measure the minimum
distance of the code, minimum
free distance.
What's the minimum Hamming
distance between any two
possible output sequences?
And in the notes, I go into
considerable detail to explain
how we choose the particular
definition of all.
What do we mean?
Do we mean the set of all
possible output sequences if
we put in a finite
input sequence?
An input sequences that starts
at time 0, and this
polynomial, let's say, that
ends at some finite time?
Are we going to allow
semi-infinite, bi-infinite
input sequences?
So you see, there's some choices
to be made here.
And actually, it's of some
importance that we make the
right choice to get proper
insight into these codes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You have to choose the
initial state, then?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
You know from linear systems
that the output isn't even
well-defined unless you say
what the initial state is.
And in general, in linear
systems, we say, well, we'll
assume it starts out in
the all-zero state.
And that's basically the choice
I'm going to make,
except I'm going to do
it in a couple steps.
But that's the right question.
How do we initialize
the system?
That's a part of the
specification of this encoder.
And of course we initialize
it in the all-zero state.
But for that reason, in a
general system, we can't allow
bi-infinite inputs.
Because if we don't know what
the starting time is, we don't
know how to define the
starting state.
Again, I'm speaking
very roughly.
So let me speak a little
bit more precisely.
We're going to define the
set of all Laurent.
Which means semi-infinite
sequences
over the binary field.
And this is called F2 of D. And
this means a sequence --
U, say --
which is only a finite
number of non-zero
terms before time 0.
In other words, it can start at
any negative time, but it
has to have a definite
starting time.
I'm not talking about the set of
all power series or the set
of all sequences that start
at time 0 or later.
The sequence can start
at any time.
But it does have to have a
definite starting time, and
before that, it has
to be all 0.
So that for instance,
the sequence that --
I haven't introduced
D transforms yet.
Maybe I should do that
immediately.
But a sequence which, at minus
5, minus 4, minus 3, minus 2,
minus 1, 0 --
these are time indices --
looks like 1 0 1 0 0 1 0, and
goes on indefinitely in the
future, but has all
zeros back here --
that is a legitimate
Laurent sequence.
Whereas a sequence that's dot
dot dot 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 and
so forth, all ones forever, is
not, because it doesn't have a
definite starting time.
And I sort of --
all right in this notation --
I need to introduce
D transforms.
The D transform of a sequence U
which has components Uk for
k and z it is simply the
sum of Uk D to the k.
Let me write that as U of
D. For all k and z.
This is simply a generating
function.
It looks very much like the Z
transform that you see in
discrete time linear
filter theory.
We would write for something
up here, well --
So a sequence that is 1
at time 0, 0 at time
1, 1 at time 2 --
if U is equal to that, and 0 at
all other times, we would
just write U of D equals
1 plus D squared.
So it's a generating function.
The D just gives us a location
of where the ones are.
It's easier to write this
than this, frankly.
It's actually hard to write
the sequence which is 1 at
time k and 0 at all other times
in this notation, but
it's simply D to the
k in this notation.
D here is algebraically simply
an indeterminate, or a
placeholder.
And this is the subtle
difference from Z transforms.
The Z transforms, we would write
U of Z minus one equals
1 plus Z minus 2 for something
like this.
There's this Z to the minus 1
convention in Z transforms.
That's not the important
difference.
We could clearly use D to the
minus 1 rather than D. The
important difference here is
that Z is usually imagined to
have values in the
complex plane.
We look for it's poles and
zeros in the complex
plane and so forth.
And so the Z transform really
is a transform.
It takes you into the
frequency domain.
If you make z equals e to the
j omega t or something, then
you're in the frequency
domain.
Here, this is still a time
domain expression.
Just as a convenient, compact,
generating function notation
for a particular sequence.
So that's when I say the set
of all semi-infinite
sequences, now I can write --
a Laurent sequence always
looks like this.
It starts off at some
particular time.
Let's say the first term is Ud D
to the d plus Ud plus 1 D to
the d plus 1 plus so forth.
It always looks like that.
So it has a definite starting
time d, which
is called the delay.
The delay of u of D is equal
to d, in this case.
And d can be any integer.
It can start at a negative time
or at a positive time.
We don't require it to start
at time 0 or later.
But nonetheless, the sequence
has to look like this.
And we indicate the set of
all such sequences here.
One of the immediate
observations that you can make
is that this is a time
invariant set.
Which the set of all sequences
that start at
0 or later is not.
Set of all sequences that start
at 0 or later has a
definite time in it, and a set
is time-invariant if D times
the set is equal to the set.
So what is D times F2 of D?
I claim it's just F2 of
D all over again.
And in fact, D to the k for
any k is equal to F2 of D.
So the set of all Laurent
sequences is time-invariant.
Whereas the set of all power
series in D, that's sequences
that have delay 0 or greater,
is not time invariant.
It does not satisfy this.
Chew on that.
An important consequence of this
is that the set of all
Laurent sequences
forms a field.
Let's say what we need
to prove for a field.
Can we add Laurent sequences?
Yes, we simply add them in the
usual way, component-wise.
Same way as you do in
polynomial addition.
You just gather together
compounds at time k.
Can you multiply Laurent
sequences?
You can certainly multiply
polynomials.
1 plus D times one plus D is
1 plus D squared over F2.
Can you multiply Laurent
sequences?
Well, yes.
We can define multiplication by
convolution as we do with
polynomials.
In other words, U of D times V
of D is the sequence W of D,
where Wk is the sum over k
prime in Z of Uk prime Vk
minus k prime.
Now what's the potential problem
that can arise when
you define multiplication
by convolution?
If any of these terms are
infinite, we have no notion of
convergence over F2.
So we really have no way of
defining an infinite sum.
An infinite sum of elements
in F2 is, in general, not
well-defined.
But from the fact that each of
these starts at one time --
this is basically multiplying
something by the time reversal.
We only have a finite number of
elements in any such sum.
So that's the real reason
for using the set
of all Laurent sequences.
If we had the set of all
bi-infinite sequences, then
multiplication would not
be well-defined.
But by insisting that they
have a starting time, we
ensure that convolution is
always well-defined.
Therefore, multiplication
of Laurent sequences is
well-defined.
OK.
So we have addition, we
have multiplication.
Maybe I'll go over here.
What else do we need
for a field?
So far we just have a ring.
Inverses, yeah.
Let's directly check inverses.
So suppose I have some Laurent
sequence U of D equals U(d), D
to the d, plus so forth.
Does that always have
an inverse?
In other words, we want to find
something 1 over U of D
equals what?
Well, let's just divide U of D
into 1 by long division, and
we can get an inverse.
Let me give you an example.
Suppose U of D is equal
to 1 plus D. What's
1 over 1 plus D?
We take 1 plus D, we divide
it into 1, we get 1.
1 plus D, D plus D,
D plus D squared.
And so forth.
So we get a semi-infinite
sequence.
Not a polynomial.
But nonetheless, it's a
legitimate Laurent sequence.
It's actually a very simple
periodic sequence of period 1.
Are you with me on this?
Could you find the inverse of
any sequence that starts at
time 0, let's say?
If you can do that, you can
certainly find the inverse of
any sequence that starts at time
D. You just multiply by D
to the minus d.
So every non-zero Laurent
sequence has an inverse.
1 over U of D, let's say.
Which is also a Laurent
sequence.
Of course, as always, we
can't divide by 0.
But that's the definition
of a field.
That doesn't matter.
We have inverses.
We checked the associative,
distributive, commutative laws.
They all work.
So this is actually a field.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
multiplication [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The Laurent sequences certainly
include polynomials,
and this is consistent with
polynomial multiplication.
So it's just extending
polynomial multiplication
really as far as we can to these
semi-infinite sequences
that are semi-infinite in the
future, but not in the past.
They're infinite in the future,
not in the past.
AUDIENCE: I think that's
[INAUDIBLE] infinite sequence
of [INAUDIBLE].
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I mean suppose you --
To find the inverse we just have
to keep solving the set
of linear equations, right?
From the first equation, we get
the first one, from the
second one, by substitution
we get the next one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's long division, which is
the same as the Euclidean
division algorithm.
We just want to find a
coefficient here that reduces
the remainder to start at time
1 or later, to have delay 1.
We want to find the next
coefficient to make the
remainder have delay 2.
And we can always continue
this, ad infinitum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: These are
semi-infinite sequences.
Do you mean sequences that
start at time 0 or later,
which are called formal
power series?
Again, there are some --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh!
Sorry, yes.
Of course, we need
to check that.
But you can see, it
doesn't matter.
We could divide by 1 plus D plus
D squared plus so forth,
and the algorithm is the same.
In that case, of course, if we
did that, we'd get 1 plus D
plus D squared, plus so forth.
D plus D squared,
plus so forth.
And what do you know?
D times that is that,
and we get 0, and it
terminates after 1.
So yeah.
Thank you.
Long division also works.
If we divide by any Laurent
sequence, it's the same.
The same algorithm.
Excellent.
OK.
So every Laurent sequence
has an inverse.
In general, what do the
inverses of polynomial
sequences look like?
Inverse of a polynomial
sequence.
Can anyone guess what its
special property is?
What is a polynomial sequence,
first of all?
I say a sequence is finite if it
only has a finite number of
non-zero terms.
I'm going to say it's polynomial
if it's finite and
also causal.
Causal means it starts
at time 0 or later.
Its delay is non-negative.
All right.
So that's the polynomials that
we're already familiar with.
What does the inverse of a
polynomial sequence look like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's always going
to be infinite, right?
Unless it's 1 or something.
So unless it's an invertible
unit in the polynomials, it's
going to be an infinite
sequence.
But it's going to
have a property.
Nobody can guess what the
property's going to be?
I already mentioned it once.
Periodic!
Right.
And this is an if and
only if statement.
I guess I have to elaborate
a little bit, but roughly,
that's correct.
This is going to be one of
your homework problems.
Maybe I'm jumping ahead a
little, but let me --
there are a couple of
ways of seeing this.
One is to use some of
the algebra we did
back in chapter seven.
But since we didn't
really complete
that, I won't do that.
A second one is to see within
this long division operation,
again, if I'm dividing by a
polynomial, there's only a
finite set of possible
remainders so I can get up to
shifts by multiples of D. So
if I see the same remainder
again, if I see 1, D, and then
D squared, of course the
series is going to have to
continue in the same way
necessarily.
Since there are only a finite
number of remainders, it's got
to repeat at some point.
Well, a way that I can do
it which is more in
the spirit of this.
Suppose I consider the impulse
response of a system with
feedback, which is set up so the
impulse response is equal
to, in this case, say, 1
over D plus D squared.
You see that the impulse
response of this is going to
be 1 over 1 plus D
plus D squared.
If I put in a 1, time 1, then
next time, I'm going to get a
1 in here, going to get a
1 feeding back there.
Well anyway, I believe
that's right.
This gives an impulse response
of 1 over --
if it doesn't, then readjust
it so it does.
Now, after time 0, the
input is always 0.
So I just have an autonomous
system which is producing the
terms at time 1 and later of 1
over 1 plus D plus D squared.
And again, it's a finite
state system.
Because for over F2, there are
only 4 states in the system.
So what could its state
transition diagram
possibly look like?
First of all, the 0
state always goes
around to the 0 state.
So the other states are
interconnected in some way.
And at best, they're always
going to cycle.
So this is a quick proof
that 1 over 1 plus D
plus D squared --
in fact, any polynomial
inverse --
is going to give you a
periodic response.
What I should really say is --
let me define a rational
Laurent sequence.
I'll leave out the Laurent.
A rational sequence is something
of the form n of D
over d of D where these are both
polynomial, or they're
actually finite.
Let's say they're
both polynomial.
You can reduce it to lowest
terms, if you like.
Actually, I should make this
finite up here, so that it can
start at time before time 0.
And I have to have d of
D not equal to 0.
And in fact, I generally require
d0, the first term
down here, to be 1.
So this is a polynomial with
time 0 term equal to 1.
Like 1 plus D plus D squared.
So a rational sequence is one
that looks like that.
We can generate a rational
sequence by feeding n of D
into a system that has response
1 over d of D. And
the output --
I forget where you take
the output off here.
Probably here.
This will be n of D
over d of D. OK.
There's a linear system.
Single input, single output.
If it has impulse response, 1
over d of D, then if I put in
the sequence n of D, I'm going
to get out n of D over d of D.
And so by the same finite memory
argument, n of D over d
of D is going to be eventually
periodic.
So a sequence is rational
if and only if
it's eventually periodic.
And again, on the homework, I'm
going to ask you to prove
this more carefully.
You can use this finite memory
argument if you like.
So this should remind
you of something.
This should remind you of real
numbers, integers, ratios of
integers, which are rational
real numbers, all
that sort of thing.
What are the analogies here?
First of all, how big is it?
How many real numbers
are there?
It's uncountably infinite,
right?
How many Laurent sequences
are there?
You can I think quickly convince
yourself that it's
uncountably infinite.
Now, we have a special
subset of the real
numbers called the integers.
Oh.
Let's think of this as a decimal
expansion, by the way.
So we have a d, a d minus 1,
and so forth, down to a0
decimal point a minus 1.
These are the coefficients
of decimal expansion.
There's something interesting
here.
Implicitly we always assume
there are only a finite number
of coefficients in the decimal
expansion above the decimal
point, right?
There can be an infinite
number going this way.
So that's completely analogous
to what we have here.
What are the integers?
The integers are the 1's
that stop at a0.
That are all zero to the right
side of the decimal point.
Over here we have something that
looks like u d, D to the
d plus u d plus 1, D to the
d plus 1, and so forth.
And in here we have a special
subclass called the
polynomials in D. And
what are these?
It's not precisely analogous,
because I should really do it
with Z minus 1, to make it
analogous and expand it in the
other direction.
But these are the ones that have
only a finite number of
coefficients to the right of
the time 0 point, again.
We noticed before that there is
a very close relationship
between the factorization
properties of Z and the
factorization properties
of the polynomials.
They're both principal
ideal domains.
They're both unique
factorization domains.
They're both rings of the
very nicest type.
Then once we have in here
the rational numbers --
that's certainly an important
subset of the reals --
how many rationals are there?
The rationals, this is basically
a ratio of integers.
And there's only a countably
infinite number
of rationals, right?
And what's the distinguishing
characteristic of the
rationals in terms of their
decimal expansion?
It's eventually periodic.
So these correspond to the
rational functions, which are
denoted by this regular
parentheses bracket.
So this is the polynomials.
This is the rational
functions.
And because these are eventually
periodic, or
because all of these can be
written as n of D over d of D,
and both of these are
polynomials, or these are
clearly countably infinite
sets, this is a countably
infinite set.
The set of all rational
Laurentian polynomials.
So again, this is
just mnemonics.
Haven't proved anything.
But the behavior of these things
very closely reminds
you of the behavior of these
things over here.
It's good to keep
this in mind.
One other point.
Suppose I'd allow bi-infinite
sequences.
Then 1 over 1 plus D doesn't
have a definite expansion.
It has two expansions.
1 over 1 plus D, if we require
that the expansion be Laurent,
then we only have this
possibility.
But if it could be bi-infinite
in the other direction, then
you can see that this is also
equal to D minus 1 plus D
minus 2 plus D minus 3 plus
so forth, semi-infinitely.
So another reason we want to
rule out non-Laurent sequences
is to have a unique inverse.
This is just another way of
saying that the Laurent
sequences form a field.
That the bi-infinite sequences
don't have the
multiplicative property.
They're simply a group.
And this is all written
up in the notes.
All right.
So where I want to get
to eventually here --
come back over here.
Let's now analyze this
convolutional encoder.
It's a linear time invariant
circuit.
That means it's characterized
by its impulse response.
Or responses, if you like,
because it has two outputs.
What does y1 of D, if I write
the D transform of y1, what is
that going to equal to?
If I just put in a single
impulse, single 1 at time 0
for u k, what am I going
to get out up there?
I'm going to get out 1 0
1 and then all zeros.
So y1 of D, the impulse response
to steps d1 of D,
equals 1 plus D squared.
That's the impulse response
of the first output.
And y1 of D is simply u of
D times 1 plus D squared,
bi-linearity and time
invariance.
So if I put in 1 plus
D squared, I'll get
out 1 plus D fourth.
Is this too quick?
This is just linear
system theory.
You've all seen this
in Digital Signal
Processing or something.
This is undergraduate stuff,
except for over F2.
OK?
You've just got to check
that it's linear, it's
time-invariant.
Therefore it's characterized
by its impulse response.
And so once you know the impulse
response, you want to
know the response to any
sequence, you convolve that
sequence with the impulse
response.
This is that statement in
D transform notation.
OK?
People happy with that?
I will spend time on it if it's
mysterious, but I don't
think it should be mysterious.
All right.
And let's complete
the picture.
What's the impulse response
for the second
output in that picture?
1 plus D plus D squared,
thank you.
So we have y2 of D is equal
to u of D times 1
plus D plus D squared.
We can aggregate this by simply
saying that a little 2
vector, y of D, is equal to a
1 vector, u of D, times a
little 2 vector, g of D, where
this means y1 of D, y2 of D,
and this means g1 of
D, g2 of D. OK?
So this is a very simple
little matrix equation.
And now the convolutional
code.
This is the output sequence in
response to a particular input
sequence u of D. So we're going
to define the code as
the set of all possible output
sequences when the input
sequences run through what?
Now, with all this elaborate
set up --
so it's the set of all output
sequences y of D equals u of D
g of D as u of D runs
through the set
of all Laurent sequences.
Sequences that start at
some definite time.
And now I've said much more
precisely what I said back at
the beginning.
Because all sequences have a
definite starting time, we
know what the starting state is
for any of these sequences.
Always when the sequence starts
at time D, the system
is quiet, it's in the all-zero
state, and it's driven from
time D onwards.
So this convolution
is well-defined.
If we had an undefined starting
state, then this
would not be well-defined.
OK.
So a long, longer
than I attended
lecture on Laurent sequences.
But it's turned out, in the
theory of convolutional codes,
it's very important
to get this right.
People have used various
definitions.
They've let this run through
finite sequences, polynomial
sequences, formal
power series.
And trust me, this is the
right way to do it.
And I don't think anyone
is better qualified
to make that statement.
So that is the way we define
a convolutional code.
Now which direction shall
I go from here?
I guess I ought to ask,
what are we going to
allow g of D to be?
In the picture up there, we
have g1 of D and g2 of D
polynomial, which means both
causal and finite.
Causal means it starts
at time 0 or later.
Finite means that it
has only a finite
number of non-zero terms.
OK.
I want to allow perhaps more
general types of encoders.
I do want the encoder
to be finite state.
So let me impose that
I want the encoder
to be finite state.
But I'm going to
allow feedback.
Which I don't have there.
If I allow feedback, then I can
get infinite responses,
infinite impulse responses.
But by the same argument that
I've already made, it's going
to have to eventually
be periodic, right?
If the encoder has
finite state.
So we have to have g1 of D
and g2 of D are general.
We're going to allow up
to n of these for
rate 1 over n encoders.
If we want this to be the
impulse response of a finite
state encoder --
they also have to be
causal, don't they.
In order to be realizable, has
to start at time 0 or later,
the impulse response.
Then I'm going to have to
require that these all be
rational and causal.
And that's the only limitations
I'm going to put
on the g of D.
So in order to get a finite
state system, I need to have
rational impulse responses.
In order to have a realizable
system,
I need causal responses.
So these are the requirements
on the impulse responses.
Otherwise I'm not going to force
them to be anything in
particular.
Now let's see.
I go into realization theory
a little bit in the notes.
Since I've spent so much time on
Laurent sequences, I don't
think I'm going to
do that here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this mean that
the denominator is also
polynomial?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
So in fact, let me always
write these.
Let me take the least common
multiple of all the
denominators.
I'm going to write these then.
g of D is going to be some
vector of polynomials up here.
I can always write the Least
Common Multiple of all the
denominators down here and have
a single denominator.
OK?
So this is going to be my
general form for a causal,
rational, single input and
output impulse response.
It's going to consist of
something like this, where
these are all polynomial.
This is a single polynomial
with d0 equals 1.
Turns out that's necessary
for realizability.
And I'll just tell you the fact,
which you can read about
in the notes.
In fact, I will leave this
mostly as an exercise for the
student, anyway.
Realizable with nu equals max of
the degree of the n_i of D,
or the degree of the
denominator.
In other words, I take all
these polynomials --
the maximum degree
of any of them --
and I call that nu.
And I claim there's
a realization
with nu memory elements.
And of course, I'm going to
assume here that I've reduced
this to lowest terms in order
to keep that down.
If I didn't have the
denominator term,
this would be clear.
If I just had g of D equal
to a set of a vector of n
polynomials of maximum degree
nu, then it's clear that just
by this kind of a shift register
realization of here
we call the constraint length
equal to the number of memory
elements, I can realize any n
impulse responses which all
have degree nu or less, right?
So the only trick is showing how
to put in a feedback loop
which basically implements this
denominator polynomial d
of D. If I start off by
realizing 1 over d of D, then
I can basically just realize
this in the same way.
And nu is called the
constraint length.
And I have 2 to the nu states.
So by constraining this to be
of this form, I've now gone
full circle.
The number of states is in
fact 2 to the nu, and in
particular, it's finite.
When I constrain the impulses
responses to be like that,
then I guarantee that I'm going
to have a finite state
realization.
So from now on, that's what
my impulse response is
going to look like.
All right.
Now let's talk about code
equivalence, or encoder
equivalence.
I've defined the code
generated --
now I'm going to characterize
an encoder by its impulse
responses, g of D. The code
generated by g of D is u of D
g of D as u of D goes
through the set
of all Laurent sequences.
Two encoders are equivalent if
they generate the same code.
Seems reasonable.
What we're really ultimately
interested in in
communications is the behavior
of the code.
In particular, the minimum
distance of the code, how far
the sequence is separated.
We're not particularly
interested in the encoder.
At the decoder, we're just
simply going to try to tell
which code sequence was sent.
So for most purposes,
probability of decoding error,
performance of the decoder
and so forth, we're only
interested in the code itself.
We're not interested in this
little one-to-one map between
information bits and
the code sequences.
So this is a reasonable
definition of encoder
equivalence.
Now, for the case of rate 1/n
codes, which is all I'm
talking about here --
1 input, n output, so the code
generator looks like this --
it's very simple.
g of D and g prime of D are
equivalent if and only if g of
D and g prime of D differ by
some multiple a of D, where I
could let a of D be any
Laurent sequence.
But then to keep everything in
the same ballpark, I think I'd
have to keep a of D rational
and causal.
But even forgetting this -- in
other words, if one is a
multiple of the other --
then the two codes
are equivalent.
That's clear because I can
invert a of D. So this is just
a single Laurent sequence,
has an inverse.
This is the same thing as
saying g of D times
1 over a of D --
which is another rational,
causal sequence, is g prime of
D.
If this is true, then the
sequence generated by u of D
when the encoder is g of D is
the same as the sequence
generated by u of D a of D when
the encoder is g prime of
D. And this is another
rational sequence.
And vice versa.
the code sequence generated by u
of D, the encoder is g prime
of D, is the sequence generated
by u of D over a of
D if the encoder
is g of D. OK?
So that's really the proof.
So this is very, very
simple theorem.
In other words, I can multiply
any encoder n-tuple g of D by
any rational causal sequence out
front, in particular by a
polynomial or 1 over a
polynomial or something, and
I'm going to generate
the same code.
This is not going to matter.
Now, to see why we might want
to take make use of this --
let's see.
Well, given this, we might want
to pick some particularly
nice encoder from this
equivalence class of encoders,
all of which generate
the same code.
And basically, I'm going to
suggest that the nicest
encoder is the one we get if we
multiply by d of D. And if
there's any common factor
of these n of D's,
we divide it out.
That will give us the least
degree polynomial encoder,
which is equivalent to
the given encoder.
If I start off with one like
this, and I want to multiply
through by the denominator to
make it a polynomial, and if
there's any common factor to
the numerator, I want to
divide it out.
And that's what I'm going to
take as my canonical encoder.
Now let me give you a little
motivation for that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's
one motivation.
It will have the simplest
realization.
It will have a feedback-free
realization by getting rid of
the denominator term.
And it will have the least
constraint length of all
equivalent encoders, and
that's a theorem too.
But that's not the primary
motivation.
Let me talk a little bit about
distance at this point.
Let me take my example
encoder again.
And let me ask, what's
the known distance
between code sequences?
This is clearly going to be an
important performance metric
of this code, right?
How would you go about answering
that question, or at
least two reasonable
ways to go?
Do you think the known distance
is greater than 1?
You think it's 1?
OK.
So how would you get
two sequences that
differ only in one place?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if you take
the impulse response.
Or you take the --
PROFESSOR: Well, the impulse
response, if I put in 1, u of
D equals 1, then I get out g of
D, which in this case is 1
plus D squared, 1 plus D plus
D squared, I actually get a
weight 5 sequence out.
You see that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you get
1 and 1 0 1, and [INAUDIBLE]
1 and 1 and 1 --
PROFESSOR: So I get this out,
in D transform notation.
Or I get 1 0 1 1 1 1 in
terms of that times
0 1 1 and so forth.
y1 equals this, y2 equals that.
Right?
OK.
So that's a weight 5 sequence.
So if I put in the all-zero
sequence, I get out the
all-zero sequence.
So as always, the all-zero
sequence is an
element of the code.
This differs from the all-zero
sequence in five places.
So all you've shown me so far is
the minimum distance is not
greater than five.
I've found two sequences that
differ in five places.
Are there any that differ in
fewer places than that?
The answer is no.
So in fact, it's called
the free distance.
For this code, the so-called
free distance is five.
Let's think of the two different
kinds of structure
for this code.
And they lead to different but
complementary arguments that
both get us to this
conclusion.
First of all, the code
is linear, right?
So C is linear.
Is it not?
If I have y of D equals u of D g
of D, and y prime of D equal
to, say, some other sequence.
u prime of D times g of D. Then
let me check the group
property, which is all I have
to check for a binary code.
And I find that y of D the
sequence, the sum of these two
sequences, is the sequence
that's generated by the sum of
the two input sequences that
led to these two sequences.
So the binary sum of any
two sequences is
another code word.
All right?
Ergo it has the group
property.
Ergo C is a group.
And that's all we
need to check.
It's actually linear over F2,
as a vector space of F2.
0 is in the code, and 1 times
any code word in the code.
So we've checked closure under
vector addition and scalar
multiplication.
So it's linear.
What is the main conclusion
we get from this?
Therefore, the minimum
distance between code
sequences is equal to --
anybody?
The minimum non-zero weight
of any y of D in the code.
Exactly the same argument.
We're talking infinite sequences
here, but there's
nothing that changes
in the argument.
And so that really simplifies
things.
We simply have to ask --
here's a non-zero sequence
of Hamming weight 5.
You can add this to any code
sequence and get another
legitimate code sequence.
This is the code sequence.
Add it to any other,
and you get a
legitimate code sequence.
So from any other code sequence,
there's going to be
one of distance 5.
Are there any lower weight
sequences in this code?
Well, what would you --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
So here's where we need
to get into much
more concrete arguments.
You can see that first of all,
we're only interested in
looking at finite sequences
in the code.
And we might as well have them
start at time 0, because if
they start later, we could just
shift them over by time
and variance.
So we're only interested in
finite polynomial sequences
that start at time 0.
OK.
So just as you said, in the
first place, they're always
going to have bing bing!
Two 1's.
When the first 1 comes
in, we're going
to get two 1's out.
For sure.
Time 2.
This is what we get out if the
second bit in, in the input
sequence, is a 0.
What happens if the second
bit in is a 1?
Then we add this to this,
shift it over 1.
We have 1 1 in particular
at this place.
We get a 1 0 out.
OK?
So we conclude at the second
time, we're always going to
get at least another
unit of distance.
Now jump ahead.
However long this is, this
is going to have
to end at some time.
At the time when the last bit,
the last non-zero bit, is
shifting out of the shift
register, we're also going to
get 1 1 out.
So any finite code word has
to end with a 1 1 at
the last time out.
People don't seem to be totally
comfortable with this,
so I'll do it in a
more elaborate
way in just a second.
But this is the basis
of the argument.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
this?
PROFESSOR: At the end?
AUDIENCE: No, I mean
by [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
at the same time.
PROFESSOR: At the end of
a finite code word?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right.
What does a finite code
word consist of?
I'm going to claim that we only
get a finite code word
out when we put a finite
input sequence in.
OK?
There's no feedback here.
So there's going to be some last
1 in the input sequence
as that shifts through here.
At the very last time,
the last state, is
going to be 0 1.
All right?
Just before that comes
out, there's a 0
coming in, forever after.
So the last time we get a 1 at
u k minus 2, and that forces
these two bits out to be 1.
Or you can do it
by polynomials.
You can always show that you
multiply this by any finite
polynomial, you're going to get
highest degree terms, both
equal to 1.
OK.
I'll do this by explicitly
drawing out the state diagram.
So we can conclude here that we
always have 2 here, 1 here,
dot dot dot dot, and finally
at the end, we have to
have at least 2.
Therefore, every nonzero finite
sequence has to have
weight at least 5.
Since we've seen one of that
has weight 5, that is the
minimum distance.
OK?
Now let's do this by drawing
the state diagram.
Which is where we're going.
AUDIENCE: So I know
that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
We had to construct a little
argument here, and in effect,
make a little search.
And this simple argument
wouldn't work for more
complicated cases.
So let me show you how to attack
more complicated cases.
We want to draw a finite
state machine.
How do you analyze finite
state machines?
Well, a good way to start
is to draw the
state transition diagram.
And I don't know what the
curriculum consists of
nowadays, but I assume
you've all done this.
We draw the four possible
states.
0 0.
1 0, we can get to from 0 0.
0 0, if I get an input of 0,
then I'm going to put out 0 0,
then I'm going to stay
in the 0 state.
All right?
Because this is linear, if the
0 comes in, that's 0 0, stay
in the 0 state.
Or a 1 could come in.
And in that case, as we've
noted, we'll put out two 1's
as our output, and we'll
transition to the state 1 0.
Now from 1 0, where can we go?
For 1 0, if a 0 comes in, then
we'll put out 0 1 and we'll
transition to 0 1.
Or we'll get another 1 in.
We would put out the complement
of that, 1 0.
So we get another 1 1 in
this linear thing.
Work it out.
I'll just assert that.
And we go to state 1 1.
From 0 1, if we get a 0 in, we
return to the 0 0 state and we
put out 1 1.
So here's our basic impulse
response, right down here.
We put in a 1, we go through
this little cycle, we come
back to 0 0.
Or if we get a 1 in, we go
back up here, and at that
point, we actually only
put out two 0's.
Is that right?
Yeah, because it has to be
the complement of this.
And if we're in the 1 1 state
and another 1 comes in, we
stay in the 1 1 state.
And we put out what?
Let me do the 0 1 first.
0, and we're in 1 1 state,
then what do we get out?
We get out a 0 down here and
we get out a 1 up there.
We got 1 0.
Or if we get in a 1,
we put out 0 1.
All right.
So that's the state transition
diagram.
Now again, let me make the
argument that I made before,
now a little bit more concisely,
because we're going
to have to stop.
So every path through this
state transition diagram
corresponds to a code
sequence, right?
Every finite or semi-infinite
path always
start in the 0 state.
For a finite code word, I have
to come back to the 0 state.
Correct?
So I'm always going to get
two 1's when I start out.
Then the next time, I'm either
going to go on this transition
or this transition, but either
way, I'm going to get at least
another unit of weight.
And then I can do whatever I
want through here for a while,
but eventually I'm going to have
to come back out here.
And when I get back to the
0 state, I'm going to
get two more 1's.
So that's maybe a lot easier way
to say the minimum weight
has to be 5.
Again, if it were more
complicated, I'd have to make
more of an argument.
All right.
Next time, when we come back,
we'll talk about turning this
into a trellis diagram.
We'll talk about
catastrophicity, which is
where I was going with this
canonical generator.
It's just a minor algebraic
point, but one you need to
know about.
We'll talk about the
Viterbi algorithm.
I think we can probably
get through
this chapter on Wednesday.
OK?
Ashish has your midterms and
the midterm solutions.